hello everyone my name is markiplier
markiplier and welcome back to three
scary games we recommend using
headphones this one is called I've
already forgotten the name of it what
was it called I forgotten the ER oh wait
a minute what I don't have arms okay
is this why I'm at the ER oh okay I've
got a weird hobble too me too
my leg okay I don't know oh this is
bizarre leading to emergency exits are
now open have a nice day thanks
what is the cocoon thing do I guess I
couldn't okay all right let's take a nap
on this gurney here not that way not
that way
oh that Kearney's real rusted someone
spilled a lot of soup on that one
Oh everyone always eating their soups on
their Gurney's and whatnot and what
happy you Oh No
No No thank you no I'm okay no I'm good
I'm fine no I heard some noises coming
from over here but I don't see nothing
no more so guess there's nothing here
oh that that's normal and the thing is
out right great
great oh oh great I'm in the coop
okay just in case I want a nicer hog is
this slightly erotic for anyone else no
one but me just wanted to emphasize the
erotic nature of what's happening okay
I'm done I swear I'm done okay all right
well that was weird
oh this is open oh god they got soup on
the walls and floor we got some messy
eaters here oh no someone really messed
up
take your time man take your time take
your time
oh wait no hey I got oh [ __ ] well I
didn't realize my moment was oh god
really
really God okay good we're here the
opportunity was
- pass me can you move
oh it follows me oh it wants to eat me
that's what it is oh here I was thinking
that it was just moving for the sake of
moving it's okay
Wow alright goodbye see you around take
care have a good day Oh Here I am
okay where is here and why am I here and
what am i doing and what's happening
alright cool
oh great there we go
I don't want to looks like you had a bit
too much soup no I don't trust this I
don't know what I can do to help you man
did what I could get for overeating on
soup it just stuff your face full of
soup and what do you expect to happen
alright time to get out of here did
someone draw a penis with soup hello hi
hello can I help you alright well let's
go back oh great
pardon me don't mind me just the Scouten
bye
oh they got soup on the floor - oh this
need to go on my comfort zone hang on a
second ah that's nice huh feels warm
okay alright just need a little bit just
need just need a little little juice
that's all I needed
okay all right
oh hey are you that guy that I was
supposed to help hello
do you need help I'm sorry for
everything I've ever done whoa whoa hey
listen buddy hi are you the soup oh you
use soup delivery I don't need any think
you have good I just carry on without me
okay see ya
huh see see ya I'll see ya see ya I'll
see you I'll see you around the bend
I'll see you I'll see you I see you see
you later all right
that was great that was awesome
I loved that love I can't overstate how
cool that was because it built up the
tension so good like of course like he
was a linear experience and of course it
was just like like the ending was just a
monster chasing you out of a door but
the feel of it the feel of that game
oh whoa okay wait a minute hey you can't
just do that twice to me hey wait a
minute
no hey wait no I gotta go to my happy
place hey you would get distracted
oh [ __ ] laughs [ __ ] oh oh you cheeky
bastard You cheeky bastard you cheeky
bastard oh you you know come on now that
is just silly all right that's pretty
good
I like that a false ending is there
actually oh yeah whatever wake up yeah
whatever is there actually anything to
do here could I could I actually get
away from this I have no idea I bet I
couldn't get away cause it's just too
close like there's no way that you could
get away from that thing oh really oh
now I can leave okay I
oh [ __ ] that's so weird
that's so weird that's so weird I love
that I love this this is so good
that's so good that is really good
that's that's something special that is
something special
hmm background again here we go let me
just pop a squat inside my warm embrace
place ah yes please let me in ah
that feels good okay I think I'm just
gonna end it here because I don't think
there's anything else to do cuz what
would happen if I go here again what
would happen if I go again
right it couldn't possibly do the same
thing right Oh
[Laughter]
I'm not gonna make it it does it has
infinite replay value it's the greatest
game ever wow that is some Spanish so
cool again again again again we go round
the bend again this will be though oh
yeah it's just the same dog okay I'm not
gonna do it again I'm not gonna go again
cuz I think that's got to be the end Oh
God oh ye gods
okay alright we're gonna call that one
where it is alright
that was cool that was cool alright
welcome to shut down I don't know his
shut downs about but it says it's
supposed to be a very scary first-person
experience let's do it oh I've cut hands
terrifying hands oh [ __ ]
I can't move I mean why am I just
standing here
oh no oh my hands hello hello hi oh oh
okay oh I grew taller it's my dream come
true I'm taller no I can't still can't
move okay I think maybe this was
supposed to be a VR experience ah well I
can't be bothered to do that okay
oh I can zoom whoosh ah good the ring my
favorite show
great oh [ __ ] oh okay that seems
important I didn't catch that
okay that's man I got an interesting
life oh hello what are the UH lamp I am
I didn't catch that
well who's there who's there I heard
breathing by milk do not forget I hate
cars disorder I don't know
[Applause]
[Music]
come on in put some tea on okay okay
okay I don't know this weird I think
this is supposed to be like a VR
experience but at the same time it's
creepy because I've never played a game
where I'm not supposed to move I am I am
I am I am I am I am I am I am Sam I am
Oh what did I do that what happened was
that my neck done bunch of my neck just
brick did my neck brick
Doug Oh toe guy whoa [ __ ] I hate it when
my furniture does this what Oh
oh oh I am something oh okay oh where am
i oh good great oh oh great oh wait no
hang on I don't want this um uh well
[ __ ] okay um no zoom oh [ __ ] oh well
okay
all right death is imminent oh here I go
goodbye oh dude oh I'm fine then I guess
okay oh there I go zooming and uh I am
crazy do not forget okay great I am
crazy apparently how could I forget
it's so apparent uh-huh Wow okay well
well I guess there we go then okay Jesus
that's it
what okay sure
rip rip oh dear it me give me some F say
whoa [ __ ] hi ru hey welcome the main
menus just as scary is the game hey are
you doing hey good to see you see ya
alright catch you later
alright guess that is all for shutdown
guess I'll have to shut her down did I
say this one was called mr. twigs
activate three altars walk to start the
game I don't want to start cuz I don't
know what's gonna happen when I start
this alright here we go
mr. twigs I think this one is very much
like a Slenderman style one you know you
got to go out you got to accomplish some
things you got to go to different
locations and then you gotta I don't
know escape or something like that which
you know reminds me I still need to
someday beat the original Slender Man
never have which is a very weird thing
when you really think about it but I
never have considering like I spent so
much time beating all those Slenderman
say shadows maps that was such a time in
my channel when those were coming out
and it was like you have to play the
next one as soon as it comes out and as
I got a beat it as fast as possible get
the video up it's like this is like this
weird race that I had but I still
remember those times that was six and a
half years ago now six and a half years
ago which is crazy to think about too
because six and a half years that's a
long time but it's not the longest time
in the world
separating me who I am now from them Oh
an alter well Oh bye
Oh bye okay Dorsia okay alright oh oh oh
why oh hi oh wait hang on how do you do
that what are you doing no I don't like
that don't like that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
gotta keep an eye on mr. twigs hang on
mr. twigs hey whoa hey whoa whoa whoa
buddy whoa buddy whoa buddy okay you
stay right okay mr. twigs Hey oh you're
doing the opposite of the Slendy man I
haven't had like a Slenderman style game
where people actually put some effort
into it in a while I don't know where
these authors are and I don't seem to
have any kind of a clue to indicate it
but guess I'll just keep wandering woo
hey buddy you're getting kind of close I
don't like it no good Oh didn't know
there were bear traps in the woods do I
do I do something about theirs but I
just don't okay there we go
all right cool Greg good good to know
that's the thing all right okay all
right well hey is that an ulcer or is
that the one I activated that's the one
I activated no it's not it is did I go
in a big circle I did I went in a big
circle I am an idiot
all right well
I'm no go I guess all right well this is
manageable this ain't too bad all it is
is finally where he is and looking at
him that's not that's not too bad
yeah the hard part's just gonna be
that's pretty hard part's it's gonna be
finding these things cuz everything
looks so similar all right where's when
is something gonna happen God where is
this thing this is what I don't like
about the Slenderman games is like the
part of the game is just learning where
things are and that's boring like it's
not exciting gameplay there's another
one this is something so give me
something give me something to fight for
here here we go all right
activated I don't know if he can
actually get me oh [ __ ]
did you are you accelerating or
something mister whoa okay all right
whoa okay a little faster a little
faster but manageable oh [ __ ] easy
enough the only problem is I can't see
where I'm going
so it's bit of an issue hello oh the
bear trap but I bet that's the bear trap
I hit okay let me go this way or maybe
it's not I don't know I don't know man
never seen this before
sure would be great oh there we go third
alter I guess yeah hello okay do I win
whoa whoa whoa well wait what what Oh
great I did it all right well what
happens if you die that I guess that's
the only other thing in this game as if
you die well that was not that wasn't
satisfying there was no payoff to that
those is death that's all that was what
a bunch of baloney what a bunch of
malarkey oh [ __ ] oh well I guess I'm
dead you can run but not forever
all right well alright that's it's it's
interesting because this game actually
does have polish and it looks good but
it's such a simple concept the gameplay
is not there it's ok it's ok I don't
wanna [ __ ] on it I I definitely don't
want to [ __ ] on it because it's not bad
it's well put together it's it's well
it's well executed it's done well the
mechanic works it's just not very fun
like that at the end of the day that's
all the criticism that you can make
about this game just not very fun so
that's it so that's all I'm gonna say
otherwise just well made yeah alright so
this one it's called mom I don't think
it's so much a game as it is more just
an experience because it's supposed to
give you the feeling of if you were kid
again and you lost your mom in a
shopping center or a grocery store all
right I don't expect this one to be very
long I've only played two or three other
horror games that took place in grocery
stores so I can't exactly say wow what
is that bad is that bad that's bad isn't
it oh yeah is that bad oh [ __ ] I'm just
a kid hey whoa hey whoa hey what do you
do we gonna do you big Oh
[Laughter]
I guess okay I like the music catchy
tunes again let's let's not let's not be
caught by the whatever that was so is
the objective to find our mother our
collective mother or is it just to keep
away from the red glowing orb that sends
you into eternal damnation and pain and
screaming don't forget the screaming
okay so let's at least map out the
circumference of this place we're gonna
run a lap around this and we're gonna
find out it's real pretty I'll give it
that it's real pretty like really pretty
in fact it's so pretty nope what is that
is that my mom mom you're not you're
you're not that's a red glowy mom mom
your mom mom
so reassuring
daddy's okay daddy's daddy's here
daddy's here
daddy's here don't worry don't cry
daddy's here her tears that he's here
come on out for food it's okay that he's
here
daddy's here
mommy's here all right well Wow Wow now
I feel like I wasn't supposed to win
that quick but yeah there you go
there you go
that was three scary games thank you so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye